Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
James Gunn just announced the new Supergirl
who's going to appear in Superman Legacy first
Then she'll go on to star in that Supergirl solo movie,
Woman of Tomorrow, based on the comic book
storyline by Tom King
She's a huge character
And everyone involved, both the actress and James
Gunn, talked a lot about her recently,
how she's going to be different from previous versions
of Supergirl in the movies and the TV versions.
So we'll break it all down and what she's going to be
doing during Superman Legacy.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They're going to be filming the movie pretty soon.
So we should actually start
getting some footage from the movie pretty quickly.
I literally just posted another Superman legacy video
for David Cornwell,
who had just worn Henry Cavill Superman
suit in his auditions to be the New Superman.
As ironic is, that is pretty much all actors
auditioning for new Superman movies
or other superhero movies in franchises
who make it far enough along the process Wait up.
Auditioning in the previous superhero's suit.
Henry Cavill, for example, auditioned for Zack Snyder
in The Man of Steel movie wearing Christopher Reeve's
Superman suit.
So it's not quite as weird as it sounds,
But the real big news you probably just saw everybody's
talking about was James Gunn just announced
he'd cast Millie Alcock from House of the Dragon
as the new Supergirl of this rebooted DCU movies.
Right now it's just for Superman Legacy.
Like, that's why he cast her.
Because we're getting ready to film with the character.
Then she'll be in the supergirl solo movie
Woman of Tomorrow, But she'll also appear as Supergirl
whenever they use the character in other movies
and other TV series.
one of the big differences with James Gunn's new era
of DC movies in the DCU, all the TV shows
is that all the movie
actors will also voiced their characters in animation
and appear on the live action TV shows
when they want them to cross over.
Really good example of that just happening in the DC.
EU is on the Peacemaker Series, where you have Aquaman
in the flesh playing their characters again on TV.
just imagine
more of that happening
they're couple exceptions to this.
Like right now
there's still multiple versions of Batman.
For example, we have Matt Reeves, Robert Pattinson's
Batman movies that will last for at least a trilogy in.
Matt Reeves is doing some some elseworlds
Batman TV series for HBO.
But that's an exception to the rule,
not the rule itself.
There is another Superman Elseworlds movie
that James Gunn just said is still in development.
He didn't sound very happy about it,
but I'll mention that at the end of the video.
So technically there's supposed
to be multiple versions of Superman,
but I'm not sure that that other Superman movie
will actually wind up making it to screen.
So for now, there's just one version of Superman
and one version of Supergirl.
generally I think that's the way to go.
It's the way they're doing it in the Marvel Universe,
naturally.
James Gunn coming from the Guardians
of the Galaxy movies patterning a lot of the way
that they structure things in this new DCU also
based on the way
that things are being structured in the MCU.
no. Big surprise. You stick with what works.
most of my experience with Millie Alcock
has been through the House of the Dragon TV series.
She plays the younger version of Rhaenyra
during the first half of season one.
and as far as I know,
The House of the Dragon showrunner said that
they don't have any plans to bring back young Rhaenyra
or young Alison or the young versions
of any of the characters in future episodes.
So she's basically done in the Game of Thrones universe
and free to do all this DC stuff.
James Gunn and everybody associated with the movie.
Even Milly Alcock herself issued a couple of statements
reacting to the casting news.
James Gunn said, Milly is a fantastically talented
young actor and I'm incredibly excited
about her being part of the DCU.
Yes, I first became aware of her
in House of the Dragon,
but I was blown away by her very audition
for Screen Test for Supergirl.
she embodies Cara, as envisioned by Thom King
Bilk is heavily in in a new era.
The reason why James Gunn name them like Thom King
the other people is because the new Supergirl
solo movie is based on Tom King's Woman of Tomorrow
comic book run.
One of my favorite comic book series from last year
was Tom King's run on Supergirl, Woman of Tomorrow.
And so we're going to turn that into a big science
fiction epic film.
Now, Superman is a guy who was sent to Earth
and raised by loving parents.
We're Supergirl in this story.
She is a character
who was raised on a chunk of Krypton.
She watched everybody around her
perish in some terrible way.
So she's a much more jaded character.
Douglas was the artist on that comic book run
who developed the visual style of the character,
which they're also using
to inform the visual style of the movie
in in a Noguera
is writing the new Supergirl movie with Thom King.
I believe Thom King is riding on it, too,
because James Gunn just featured him with a snapshot
of all the architects
of these upcoming DC movies and TV shows.
And he was there.
So it's not them just borrowing from comic book runs.
He has some of the original comic book writers actually
working on the movies and TV shows in a bigger way.
Thom King was also working on The New Gods in Dark Side
Movie DC too, before this, a couple of years ago.
But that went away when James Gunn rebooted everything
The funny thing is that right after James
Gunn posted his reaction, he also followed up by saying
that when he was watching Millie
Alcock on House of the Dragon Season
one at the time, like this is a couple of years ago
in 2022, when the show actually aired,
he told the co-head of DC Studios, now Peter Safran.
The two of them
kind of formed the Kevin Feige situation running DC.
he told him that Millie Alcock
would make a great Supergirl.
Basically,
she was his first fan cast for the new Supergirl role.
funny that months and months went by.
He probably auditioned hundreds of actresses
for the role, went through all this different process,
only to cast his original fan cast
Millie Alcock herself also issued a statement
basically saying, Thank you for entrusting me
with Caro with this character.
So she sounds pretty hyped up
she was literally featured in this viral video
of someone going to her house like the day
that she actually auditioned for the Super Bowl role.
It's like this video was taken right as she was
auditioning and winning the role of Supergirl.
this is a crazy coincidence.
Like the person that took the video had no idea
that she was auditioning for Supergirl at the time.
Like, it was just some random video
that someone was taking for their channel.
the other actress she beat out for the role in
the end was McDonnell Lee, who at the moment
has actually been voicing Supergirl
in the Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths movies.
Like I literally just did a trailer video for part two.
It's a three part movie
because crisis is such a big story.
They just released part one.
she also did her voice
during the Legion of Super-Heroes movie.
So she's basically like the tomorrow verse
version of Supergirl.
if you watched any of those movies,
you have a pretty good idea of what her Supergirl feels
and sounds like What are you asking
why he didn't just use the McDonald's version?
And I think the idea is that the Tom King version
of Supergirl and Woman of Tomorrow
is just a very different version
of the character than this tomorrow versus version.
in according to all of them.
Millie Alcock just did the best version of the version
of Supergirl that they want in the movies
like there are a lot of amazing actresses out there
that would make great super girls,
but not the version of Supergirl,
like the tone of Supergirl or what they want.
The character to be doing,
that Millie Alcock will be doing in a the two of them,
I just feel like Millie Alcock probably
a vastly bigger star, even though in both cases
is corporate synergy like they were both under contract
at Warner Brothers for different types of movies.
so even though James Gunn doesn't care about that kind
of stuff, like he's going to cast whoever he thinks
is best for the role, the Warner Brothers, people like
the corporate business suits, love that kind of stuff.
We just had this huge contract
with you for House of the Dragon.
It's going to be so much easier
for us to make a contract with you for the DC movies.
Now, James Gunn says she's going to be a critical part
of the plot in Superman legacy.
But here's the thing.
During Superman Legacy,
he's going to be reckoning more with his origin story
as a son of Krypton, as an alien,
and as a human of Earth.
so he's grown up on Earth
without knowing anything about his Kryptonian heritage.
For the most part, he has the fortress of solitude.
So I'm guessing that Supergirl is featured
when he's looking at things
inside the Fortress of Solitude,
learning about Krypton's history.
If she's actually featured
being on Earth with Superman.
I think that's not to like the very end of the movie
or maybe like a post-credits scene
or something like that.
the major difference
between her new Supergirl in the previous versions
that we've seen on screen,
it sounds like based on the Tom King run,
this Supergirl will be a way darker, way moodier
kind of characterization
than the bubbly, sweet, happy version from, say,
like the DC TV's Supergirl, played by Melissa Benoist.
I know.
A lot of you are also asking about Sasha K's Supergirl
from the Flash movie.
If they wanted a darker and more hardcore Supergirl,
why didn't they just bring her back?
because that's basically who her Supergirl was.
I think the easy answer to that is that James
Gunn wanted a total reboot of all the major characters.
The only actors that are supposed to be surviving
the DC reboot and coming back as their characters
are a few minor characters or secondary characters
that might be a little bit larger
but are so amazing as the characters,
you can't picture anyone else like his.
Amanda Waller from the Suicide Squad movie in.
John Cena's Peacemaker, for instance, is coming back.
Most of the Peacemaker actors.
but all the Justice League characters
and associated major superheroes all being recast.
but I do think Sasha Kai did a great job
with Supergirl.
Despite only being a smaller part of the Flash movie.
one of the other major differences, too,
is that Tom King's version of Supergirl
has a very, very different origin story.
there's no crazy multiverse
subplot like there was in the Flash movie
and one of the ironic things
is that Sasha Carrier actually said that the Supergirl
Woman of Tomorrow comic book run that Tom King
did was one of her favorite comic book runs.
Like she talked about it at length
during the Flash press tour.
And Supergirl Woman of Tomorrow.
We get to see this. This
is character Grieve.
You know, like, she's going. She's.
She's there's a lot of grief
because she's kind of processing.
And it starts with,
you know, her humanity as well, which I love about her.
She's not like your typical hero.
She's really just like trying to process
like you and me on a day to day.
Like, gosh, she should probably get therapy as well.
You know, she's she's just trying to figure things out,
which is incredible.
But I just I hope to do
I want I want people to see all of her.
I think that comic book is really, really cool
because you do experience her grief
and and kind of like her motherly instinct
in a sense, and her protectiveness and her care.
And I have a Great Dane.
I love my Great Dane deeply.
And her relationship with her
dog is is is really beautiful.
the irony is not lost on us that she loves Tom King
but was not right for that version of Supergirl
in the movie.
Based on that story.
But when James Gunn is talking about it,
he calls it more of a sci fi movie.
The whole idea is that it's Supergirl going
to the ends of the universe to save an alien girl.
So it's more of a space based movie.
It features Krypto the Superdog.
They're also doing Krypto in the Superman legacy
movie, too,
So we're finally getting
a version of krypto in the movies,
But because James Gunn has started ramping up
on production of Superman Legacy.
They'll be filming really soon
We should get some actual footage from the movie
pretty quickly
So whatever winds up releasing,
of course, I will do videos for click here
for my brand new Deadpool 3 teaser and click here
for that other new Superman Legacy video
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!